hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website.com and today are going to
be looking at a game between two players
BAE's versed Palmer and the game was
playing 2004 it was featured on chess
Gamescom as the game of the day not too
long ago and both players are around a
2000 rating so they're definitely not
GM's but keep in mind that even if
you're watching a GM game you know
they're playing at a much higher level
than these guys but even these guys
rated 2000 you can still learn quite a
bit from their games and just because
you're rated 2000 doesn't mean you won't
have an epic game so this is definitely
an epic game in my opinion and a lot of
people agreed which is why was a game of
the day on chess Gamescom so we're going
to go ahead and get into it and it
starts with pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 Knight to c3 looks like
going into the Knights game here and
then Knight to f6 development so we
currently here on the four Knights game
now if it was me in the situation I
would have played the Halloween gambit
Knight takes on e5 I am a super
aggressive player this is an actual
tournament so a lot of times you won't
see players especially rank 2,000 or
above try anything like the Halloween
gambit but a lot of times they are well
versed in the opening that they're
playing and white brought his Bishop to
b5 now I do want to talk about the next
move black brought his Bishop to d6 I
would have really liked him to bring his
Bishop down to b4 kind of
counter-attacking at the same time this
knight on c3 I feel like the bishop on
d6 it kind of hinders his development
you're only playing a little passive
defense trying to hold on to this e5
pawn keep in mind that if white takes on
c6 here this night here on c6 is the
lone defender currently of this pawn
here on e5 so yes he is defending it
with his bishop on d6 but he's really
hindering the development of his
LightSquared Bishop on c8 since he can't
move his pawn on d7 it's really going to
take a little time for him to get his
LightSquared Bishop into the game which
we'd really like to do anytime
you do play chess you really want to get
your minor pieces into the game and then
start to get your major pieces into the
game now from here white played pawn to
d3 he could have easily castled king set
obviously castling kingside is going to
happen eventually
but since he got his LightSquared Bishop
out usually want to get your bishops out
before you close them in and pawn to d3
is going to not allow him to develop his
light square bishop so he developed his
light square bishop first and now he
played d3 so that he can get his dark
squared bishop into the game whatever he
wants to obviously he can castle but
this pawn on d3 there's no really
threats right now so he's just building
up the center control opening up lines
for his dark square bishop and also
allowing him to castle on the King side
now black right away really does not
like this night here on c6 being pinned
down by this bishop so he's going to
start to bring his pawns into the action
and try to kick this Bishop out of the
way
now the pawn that excuse me the bishop
now is going to come back to c4 and
you'll see this a lot of times any when
white brings his light square Bishop to
b5 you have two options bringing it back
to e a four here or bringing it to c4
putting a lot of pressure on this f7
Square obviously in chess early on the
f7 Square is a very big weakness for
black especially if he hasn't castled on
the King side or even on the Queen side
yet but since this black King hasn't
moved yet the c-4 Square is a very good
square for the light square Bishop is
attacking it anytime we can bring our
knight here to g5 set up a little double
attack here
but this is going to put a lot of
pressure on this f7 Square especially if
we ever want to bring it back to b3 we
can even make room if we advance our a
pawn then we can stick our Bishop back
on a two so this Bishop here on c4 is
putting a lot of pressure now once we do
move our Bishop back to c4 now black has
the option to bring his Bishop to c5 as
well because again he was only on this
d6 square to defend this ePHI pawn and
it was only being defended by this c6
Knight since the c6 Knight is no longer
being attacked we
now bring our Bishop to c5 now it's
White's move and this is a very
important situation in the game we've
kind of come to the point where the
beginning of the game turns into the
middle game which is very important in
chess and as you kind of look at it both
sides have about the same setup here now
King side castle for white here black
has not castled yet he does have a pawn
here on a6 but as far as the middle of
the structure the minor pieces they are
all completely the same so white really
has to figure out how he wants to
continue now keep in mind if you're
white you usually want to stay ahead in
tempo and so in this case you really
want to play a move that's going to keep
you ahead as far as development so keep
in mind when we talk about our Bishop
here on c4 attacking this pawn on f7 and
the square in general at the same time
black his Bishop here on c5 is also
attacking are not our excuse me our pawn
on f2 which is a huge weakness for us
even though we are Castle down the King
side it's still a huge weakness here for
white so what I would do and I would
recommend is to play Bishop to e3 now
why why would I do this because if he
takes we're going to have doubled pawns
here on the e-file well I would do it
for two reasons one I don't think
there's another great move and so what I
normally do is I look at what are blacks
strengths right here and I see that this
dark square bishop here on c5 is a huge
strength that's developed nicely and at
the same time it's attacking a huge
weakness for us now if he does take if
he takes here on e3 and we recapture
doubled pawns in the middle are not
nearly as bad as double pawns on the A
or B files so yes we do have double
pawns but they are on the e-file which
is not as bad and we are defending this
square on d4 and the square on f4 at the
same time if you key if you look at this
situation we're really starting to put a
lot of pressure on this F file
specifically this f7 pawn now again I am
a very aggressive player so keep that in
the back your head but our rook here on
f1 is now on a semi-open file and we can
it start to attack
this f7 square for black so if we do
ever move our Knight out of the way
depending on where we want to move it
we really are opening up a lot of doors
that's to start to attack on the king
side for black so going back white did
not choose this instead he chose pawn to
h3 then this is really just a waiting
move doesn't really want to commit to
anything really doesn't want black to
develop his LightSquared bishop here to
g4 pinning down his Knight to the Queen
now if he was afraid of that you know he
could have always brought his Bishop to
g5 pinning the knight down to the Queen
but he opted for the safer route the h3
move kind of waiting to see what blacks
going to do now from here black has to
start thinking about the same thing he's
approaching the middle game and he has
to figure out how to attack white so in
this case he sees that this Bishop here
on c4 as we talked about is a huge
strength for white it's attacking this
pawn here on f7 and so he really wants
to try to get this Bishop out of the
game so he played which i think is the
correct move his Knight to a5 attacking
this bishop with the same play at the
same time there's really no place for
this LightSquared bishop to go anywhere
he moves it Black has the option to take
it so from here
white just go ahead and disregards this
bishop he's going to recapture with his
pawn here from d3 and instead he starts
to go on the attack he brings his Bishop
to g5 and black comes in and he takes
with his knight on c4 which i think is
the correct move it's taking away a huge
threat his knight on c6 wasn't doing too
much and so he exchanged it for what I
feel is the strongest minor piece that
white had in the game this Bishop here
on c4 so even a small move like that
bringing his Knight to a5 you really
have to figure out what your strengths
what your strengths are as well as what
your opponent strengths are and then
start to attack those and find the
weaknesses in your opponent's game so
from here as you can imagine white
captured on c4 and then black brought
his pawn to h6 really trying to
get rid of this pin that we have here on
this night on f6 white here not wanting
to give up his last bishop brought his
bishop back to h4 and now one of the
decisive moves in the game Black has
made up his mind as you can tell he is
not castled on the King side and I don't
know exactly what Palmer was thinking
but I probably think if in the back of
his head the entire game since he hadn't
castled already on the King side that he
was really looking to play aggressive on
the King side and castle on the Queen
side and we can tell from his next move
pawn to g5 that that's exactly what he
intends to do you're not going to play
pawn to d5 and then castle on the King
side that just doesn't make sense
because your King side is completely
obliterated as far as safety is
concerned so he's really looking to get
his Queen out of the way and get his
Bishop out of the way and then castle on
the Queen side and really start to
attack on this King side for white any
time both sides Castle on different
sides it's really going to be dis
complete chaos now here's where the
chess game really took a turn for the
worst as far as White's concern white is
completely find in the situation if he
brings his Bishop back to g3 he has a
fine game again he the game is equal
right now in my opinion and this is
completely fine for white and black
starting to overextend himself a little
bit on the Kings side and White has a
lot of different options to start to
counter-attack on the Queen side but
instead of bringing his Bishop back to
g3 which is a completely safe Square he
went ahead and captured on g5 and
obviously when black recaptured black
captured with his Bishop on g5 now this
really says that blacks really trying to
attack and he's trying to attack by a
sacrifice now he did give up one of his
minor pieces for two pawns from black
but you really got to figure out why he
did this now black is not committed to
each side he hasn't committed to the
king side more than likely he's going to
commit to the Queen side you really only
want to do a sacrifice like this on you
know the pawns
if the king has committed to one of
these sides once Kent the this black
Keene castles on the Queen side the
advantage for white as far as his attack
is not going to be there anymore so I
find this move pretty hard to justify
for white trading you know material and
losing a piece and material just for the
sake of doing it because his attacks
really not going anywhere and the King's
really not in danger right now
white really doesn't have any options to
continue his attack here now from here
it's blacks move and he brought his rook
to g8 setting up this if he takes with
his bishop here on h3 so white seeing
this brought his pawn to h4 now if you
look in this situation take a minute and
think what you would do for black in
this case and will black did is he
actually played pawn to c6 I'm not sure
I completely agree with this keep in
mind that we've really started to put a
lot of pressure on this King side this H
pawn has come up to h4 so this is really
weakening this h-file which we can
easily put pressure on and at the same
time really all we have to do is castle
on the Queen side for black and then we
can start to really put a ton of
pressure on the white king side right
here so I would really recommend
bringing our Bishop down to g4 it really
gains a tempo at the same time it makes
way for us to castle on the Queen side
it getting a tempo meaning that we're
attacking this Queen on d1 so he's going
to have to move his queen in response to
this move at the same time now we can
develop our queen and then castle on the
Queen side he can't develop one of his
minor pieces right now or start to
defend his King anymore because he has
to move his Queen here or he's going to
have to move you know Knight to e2 he's
going to have to respond to our bishop
here on g4 but instead of playing Bishop
to g4 he first played pawn to c6 and
white played King to h1 kind of just a
waiting move at the same time he really
wants to get his King out of the way of
this rook here on g8 eyeing down at the
same time this Bishop here on c5 is
down these dark squares again remember
this dark square Bishop on c5 has been a
pain the entire game lying down this
pawn here on the f2 square which is
still a huge weakness for white
now black decided to bring his Queen to
e7 not a whole lot of options where he's
going to bring his queen he has three
moves right here again eventually he's
going to bring his Bishop into the
action so he can castle on the Queen
side get all his pieces involved again
it's not how many pieces you have in
chess it's how many pieces you have
available to attack your opponent so
even if you're down in material if you
have more pieces involved in the attack
a lot of times that's going to be a
better game for you so just keep that in
mind
black really wants to get all his pieces
involved even though he is up in
material so what white from here he
starts to try to get aggressive and he
plays pawn to f4 this is partly one of
the reasons that he played King to h1 he
really wants to try to counter-attack
now he is counter attacking at the same
time weakening his Kings side so I'm not
really sure if that's the best move but
he is he does realize that he is down in
material and at the same time his King
is starting to get a lot of pressure on
him so he wants to try to do everything
he can to try to counter-attack he knows
it's not going to be a draw game and so
he's going to do everything he can to
try to win the game that's black move
and he chose the now bring his Bishop to
g4 which is a move I really like it
really develops a piece and at the same
time allows him to castle on the Queen
side whenever he wants to
black excuse me white from here brought
his queens that you want again he was
being attacked so he had to do something
about this Queen and now black started
to take pieces he took this pawn on f4
and now white took with his rook on f4
now if you want to pause this game this
was a decisive move in the game there
are a few other moves that you know
could have definitely been played but
this really brings us to a fundamental
idea in chess so if you want to pause
and just think what you would have done
and not kind of go over what was played
in the game
and was played in the game was rook
takes on g5 and as you can see from the
game he traded a rook for a bishop and a
pawn after the pawn takes he now brought
his queen
down to e5 attacking this rook and at
the same time attacking this pawn here
on g5 so he's going to take one of them
most notably this rook is going to move
or this Queen is going to come into the
action the fitness rook and he's going
to take this pawn on g5 so he does move
down as far as material advantage by one
point but what this really does is it
really takes this key to finding away
from g5 and black really understands
what we talked about is it's not how
much material you have it's how much
material you have in the game and he
realized that white had this huge piece
right here this bishop really holding
down a lot of the fort here as far as
the protection and he knew if he took
this and then took this pawn then this
h-file would be open and at the same
time once he Castle he could really
start to put tons of pressure on this
White King side right here on this h1 at
the same time this rook here on a1
although it is kind of equalizer as far
as material points it's not doing too
much and it's going to be really hard
for him to get into the action he's not
going to be able to defend anything and
it's going to take him a few moves for
he can even attack a black so black saw
this and he said you know what I'm going
to lose material and sacrifice my rook
so that I can completely dominate with
all the pieces that I do have on the
board
so from here white chose to bring his
queen to g3 he really wants to keep his
rook here on f4 and he's just going to
give up his pawn here on g5 now with his
Queen here on g3 black does have two
options he could have brought his knight
here to h5 attacking both this rook and
the Queen he chose just to go ahead and
take this pawn on g5 I'm sure this was
kind of in his head as far as he wanted
to take this bishop and this pawn here
on g5 from here white
moved rook to f1 again white really has
to get his other rook involved or else
he's going to be down way too material
way too much material as far as
attacking so he's just trying to do
everything he can to counter-attack and
now black castle to the Queen side which
is kind of what we've been waiting for
most of the game and now he can really
get his other rook into the game and
once he brings his rook to h8 it's
really going to be hard for white to
stop all the attacks that black has and
again the same time black still has this
punt this Bishop here on c5 which I'm
sure whites just been infuriated about
and again he really should have brought
his Bishop to e3 a long time ago and
traded that off because this Bishop on
c5 even though we have all our major
pieces getting into the action this is
really a decisive move and peace for
black just having his bishop hanging out
here on c5 attacking this diagonal and
really minimizing where this white king
can move to from here is kind of a
formality white decided to move his
Queen back to h2 so that black couldn't
ride away play h8 where obviously the
Queen could take the rook on h8 but from
here black decided to keep up the
pressure and he moved his knight to h5
again his knight was being attacked here
so he decided just to attack this rook
here on f4 from here white played pawn
to g3 trying to defend this rook on that
4 even though it's going to be taken so
black takes and after he retakes the
Queen is now brought to g7 which is a
great square that's still putting a lot
of pressure on this open G file now at
the same time if we were to move this
bishop we can now move this bishop
wherever we want this dark square Bishop
is putting a lot of pressure on this
long diagonal here and we're still going
to hold down this G file at the same
time we can always bring our rope to the
H file and now we have a defender
against it so if we bring our rook to h8
we're not only attacking the Queen and
the
King but the same time it's defended so
white can't just come in and take it on
h8 from here White's all that he could
bring the rook to h8 and so he brought
his King to g2 to get rid of that and
black played Bishop to e2 attacking this
rook on f1 at the same time a discovered
attack attack with this Queen here from
g7 so the game was pretty much lost and
white went ahead and resigned from here
so this was a brilliant game I thought
so much to learn from the game as far as
position different things to look at as
far as your opponent's weaknesses their
strengths what you should do as far as
forming a gameplan so hope you guys
enjoy this video if you have it already
please subscribe and also check out the
website the chess website calm and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching